this is a production of cornell
university
yeah so my name is jason londo and i'm a
research geneticist with the usda ars
and i study grapevine genetics
and in january i'll be switching over to
cornell university as an associate
professor in fruit physiology and the
point of that position will be to study
how fruit crops adapt to climate change
so today i'd like to share with you a
little bit of our experimental vineyard
here on the mccarthy farm in geneva new
york where i
i'm not a classical breeder i don't
breed for cold far release but i use
breeding techniques to try to gain
information on important traits in
grapevine
and so
what you see here
suppose if you see through the hedges
here is our experimental research
vineyard
and you're looking at a genetic mapping
population that i uh created by
combining two wild species vitus riparia
and vitus rupestris
the two species are really important for
grapevine root stocks
but they don't get used so much for
scion breeding
due to their lack of really good fruit
quality
what you're looking at here
in with every individual is a half
sibling and so it's all from the same
mapping population but they're all
related
if you come in and look close
so what you're looking at here in this
particular individual this is a female
vine and you can tell because you can
see all the developing fruit forming on
here
while grapevine species are either male
or female
each vine is either male or female and
in this case this is a female
you compare that to a male vine which
you can see over here
you can see here's the same flower
cluster but now all the flowers have
fallen off and you can see there's no
developing berries
this is one of the easy tools that you
can use when you use wild grape vines
because it's you collect pollen from one
vine and you supply it to the female
vine to make the cross
if you use a hermaphroditic vine like a
cultivated variety you have to go into
each flower and dissect out the male
parts so that you can make the cross
so you might be wondering why you would
make a cross between two wild species if
you don't really like to eat the fruit
and the reason i made the cross was to
try to learn about
stressful adaptations
adaptations to the soil adaptations to
the climate
that are held within the wild grapevine
species that are missing from cultivated
grapevine
and the innovative thing about using
this mapping population is we've taken
all the plants here all the half
siblings and we've cloned them and
placed them on this side of the vineyard
where we've mechanically grafted a
cultivated variety on top of the roots
of the vines behind me
when we do that we can see what effect
the roots have on the chute phenotype so
we can measure things like leaf
nutrition fruit berry quality
growth habit water use all of that
as the roots are controlling it
so what we're looking at here is down on
this portion this is the root stock this
is the mapping family individuals from
the vines behind here's the graft union
where you see this bulge and this part
of the vine is the cultivated variety
marquette which we've mechanically
grafted on top
and so the root and the shoot
communicate to one another
through this union and we're trying to
understand if we change out the genetics
of the root how much of the shoot can we
change
so one of the other approaches that i
use uh with breeding wild species is try
to get an understanding of how different
species react to changing climate in
particular how early spring warming and
then freezes affect grapevines and so
what we have here on this side of the
trellis is a cross between two wild
species by this scenario from down
around texas and
vitus riparia from up in south dakota
if we look over on this side
we have the same vitus scenario from
texas
but this time crossed with a species
from china called vitus amurensis
both amurensis and riparia are very cold
hardy but wake up very early in the
spring and scenario is very cold hardy
but has very late bud break and you can
see some of the effects of that
difference in timing when you look at
these two mapping families
if i grab a
cluster
here you can see that this
cross has already flowered
all the flowers are off and little
berries are forming
but this
cross
which is a half sibling
you can see none of the flowers have
opened yet
and so in each of these crosses the
parents are producing very different
flowering phenotypes and that is because
it's affecting all of the life cycles in
the grape
this one all the flowers are closed
whereas this one they're all open and
done already and
it would be tricky if you didn't know
what to look for but you can see that
the little berries are forming there
and the thing that's interesting about
these two comparisons
is they both have
the same
mother
they have two different species fathers
but the same mother and you get very
different
growth and development out of the two
crosses
some of the traits that we look at when
we're trying to understand climate
impacts on grapevine aren't very easy to
see because it's what is going on
internally inside the leaves and the
vines themselves
and so what we do is we normally measure
things like how efficient do the leaves
take up carbon dioxide how much
photosynthesis are they doing given
certain light conditions and then what
sort of ratio to carbon intake and water
loss happens at the leaf level and i
don't have the equipment out here to
show you
but we basically clamp things onto the
leaves and then measure how the leaf is
breathing within different chambers and
get an idea of how the whole vine is
responding to given treatments
look at that leaf morphology with these
really deep sinuses and the teeth it's
so very different from a lot of you can
see here
this is a more normal looking grapevine
leaf
[Music]
there's just so much diversity between
species and between the way that
sorting goes this is a cross between two
wild species
one species is vitus estebalis which
grows along the eastern seaboard and
vitus riparia which grows along the
eastern seaboard but also all the way up
into canada and out to the great plains
these two these two vines are siblings
from the same cross
and you can see very different
growth morphology look the size of these
leaves
are enormous and you get this
dark um purple cane material that's very
akin to vitus estibolis one parent
and then you have this
vine which has got this much more
rusty
sort of yellow tinged leaves
much smaller not so much vigor that's a
lot more like the riparia parent the
other parent in the cross and so here
just between these two individuals you
see
those two genetic backgrounds diverging
and so their siblings just like what we
were looking at before
these two are
brother sister brother brother sister
sister whatever you want to call it
but they're segregating
for that leaf that compound leaf trait
but the concept behind it
is if you have a really hot sunny day
and you have really big
flat leaves
you know something like that
and really dense canopy it absorbs a lot
of heat and there's not a lot of airflow
and so if you could
make a cross
so your canopy was
open and airy
then you'd have more dappled light
getting into the into the berry region
and you'd have more air flow for
sprayers for natural wind movement
and so
it's a concept where we don't really
know if it would be widely adopted
but we're trying to figure out how to
modify the entire canopy through just a
few genes
and in this case
it we know where the gene
that is doing this phenotype making this
compound leaf we know where it is in the
genome
and so that's the concept behind
this
bit of breeding
try to figure out how to open up the
canopy naturally
so one of the questions we have is if
you were to compare two canopies one
made up of the simple leaf and one of
the compound leaf does the compound leaf
canopy cool faster as you can see here
even in the wind with these compound
leaves there's a lot more air flow
through that leaf surface you have
smaller boundary areas so you should be
able to you know breathe better and so
we need to ask the question is do leaves
that are shaped like this cool faster
than leaves that are shaped like this
and also if you compare
the surface area of the two is the
little bit of leaf surface area that
you're losing in the compound leaf does
that have an effect on the overall
efficiency of photosynthesis in the vine
as as things get hotter and muggier
you need
you need good air flow
for the health of the inside of the
canopy and
and it might be that this compound leaf
variety is the way to go
as an aside we're also
i think this would make like a really
good ornamental another thing that this
one has
is it has purple
so this comes from a cultivar called
purpuria and so the trait for this leaf
red color is in that background now this
is the simple one so that doesn't it's
not in the right background yet but
imagine if you could put the purple
in with the compound
then you could then you could really
start getting some interesting
ornamentals
and you can layer things right you can
layer in
maybe some variegation
so if you had white streaked through
there so you'd have pink and white and
green and yellow you know all sort of
layered
ready yes
so what we'll wait for the semi
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu